hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and Star Wars
Episode 8 the last Jedi might have been
me medius most narrative lepak Star Wars
film I've ever feasted on and guys I'm
stuck stuffed with Easter eggs subtle
visual music choices cameos and
callbacks we passed our worst films
little cool things the movie did too
full shadow and pay off itself now I
know some fans weren't crazy about all
the elements in the last Jedi but trust
someone who's seen it so many times he's
now on first-name basis with a MC
Escher's the more you watch this movie
the more you'll love it so breathe reach
out and join an obsessive fanboy as we
re watch together the last Jedi to point
out everything you've missed and
spoilers ahead if you haven't seen the
movie get out of here you dum-dum let us
begin as all films of the Star Wars saga
do with the opening crawl the first new
texts we see for this movie is the
first-order rains this simple sentence
was actually a crucial move by the
filmmakers many viewers of the force
awakens responded that they weren't
totally clear how impactful the
resistances victory was with the
destruction of Starkiller base did the
resistance win not quite it's funny how
after many fans watched the original
Star Wars they assume the rebels
destroying the Death Star was the end of
that war too not quite like many things
with JJ Abrams movie history
definitely repeats itself along with the
audience celebrating way too soon so
like the opening crawl of the Empire
Strikes Back which began with the
sobering line it is a dark time for the
rebellion Rian Johnson made it very
clear here that the resistance is on the
defensive then after the crawl finishes
the last Jedi follows Star Wars
tradition by panning - a shot of a
spacecraft in this case this is the
resistance flagship a cruiser called the
Radice it's named after Admiral Radice
the rebel leader who led the mission to
retrieve the Death Star plans whom we
saw in rogue one last year it's fitting
that this movie opens with this memory
of a tragic rebel sacrifice that left
but a spark alive that would later bring
down the Empire summed up then by a
young general Organa hope hope you've
got a lot of hope because this movie is
gonna be a downer down on the rebel base
of Dakar we see lieutenant conics
returning from the force awakens she's
played by Billie lourd real-life
daughter of Carrie Fisher her role has
been very much expanded for this movie
so as a roll of
Huck's played by Donald Leeson joining
him as first order officers are a few
familiar cameos captain Peavy the
officer who reports to him is Adrian
Edmondson British sitcom actor and the
technician below it's kate vicki AKA
liza erin on Game of Thrones
over on the dread-nots the captain
Kennedy is another game of Thrones actor
Mark Lewis Jones he played Shagga the
hill tribesmen in season 1 behind the
scenes many of the some performers of
the last Jedi have also worked on Game
of Thrones
then when Poe confronts the Star
Destroyer in his x-wing it's an
interesting exchange between him and
bb-8 the Droid beats nervously and Po
responds happy beeps everybody come on
then Leo weighs in over the transmission
I'm with the Droid on this now people
have been pointing out that we don't
really hear anyone explicitly say in
this movie the line that's a classic
running gag of all the Star Wars movies
ryan johnson insisted on twitter that
the line was in the movie and based on
the context of this exchange baby it's
probably saying the line here i'm sure
we'll get confirmation when the binary
droid speak translation comes out let's
talk about leia here this is carrie
fisher's final on-screen performance and
it may be her finest acting as a
character she conveyed both the
weariness of a resistance leader and the
spark and the width that Leia has always
possessed I got her hair and wardrobe
according to the movies visual
dictionary Laius hair is wrapped in a
mourning braid traditional to her home
planet of Alderaan
she has also changed her clothes to
muted colors to reflect her ongoing
mourning for Han Solo when Poe teases
Huck's holding for general Hux hello he
undercuts the seriousness of this
situation with a humor that's very
similar to the way he began the force
awakens to the tux first Ito first I
talk first in both cases it indicates to
us that these movies aren't being so
sacred when it comes to everyone's
outlook on these events during this
battle Poe talks with this a winged
pilot her name is Talia entre PO
actually has a special affection for a
wing pilots and the Star Wars novels
Poe's mother was named Shara Bey and she
was an alien pilot during the Battle of
Endor
maybe you also noticed this ring that
Poe carries on a necklace around his
neck according to the visual dictionary
that ring was given to him by his mother
so it's possible that maybe Tali reminds
him in some ways of his mother these
resistance bombers are based like many
Star Wars spacecrafts are on classic
real world bombers with a three-person
crew consisting of a
pilot to Bombardier and a gunner to
protect the ship Brian Johnson said that
he was inspired by the movie 12 o'clock
high which is about an American bomber
crew during World War 2 he had his crew
watched this movie before last July
production began and you can see how
some of the shots of the Gunners
inspired the battle imagery of this
thing the gunner who saves the day here
is Paige Tico she's the sister of rose
and we meet later they both carry this
same hazy and smelts medallion pendant
around their necks
when Stokes hologram surprises Huck's on
the bridge turning them into a human
Swiffer this is actually an important
indicator that shows us the depth of
snoke's force abilities the fact that he
can force pull and push Huck's around
despite being in a totally different
location tells us that Stokes powers
transcend great distances which will
definitely come into play later when he
reveals he was the one who linked Rey in
Thailand now before we see Finn in this
hilarious leaking back that healing suit
I like that the designers included the
detail of these Arabic letters on the
lid they translate to the word stable
I'm actually obsessed with all the
Arabic the designers snuck into this
movie and I'll be pointed out more as we
go I also like how this scene with Poe
ends in this exchange you must have a
thousand questions and then Finn
responds where's ray this is a fun wink
from the script directly to the audience
we are also coming in this movie with a
thousand questions and really the only
one we want answered right now is where
the hell is Ray and immediately we move
on to Ock - and find out this scene
picks up immediately where the force
awakens left off with Ray handing Luke
his old lightsaber cool detail here if
you look closely at Luke's artificial
hand notice how it still has the blaster
scar from when it was shot at the
beginning of Return of the Jedi and Luke
chucking the saber over his shoulder is
an early example of this films deeper
meaning these precious moments aren't
meant to be seen as sacred the last Jedi
asks us to let go from the past and
explore these characters as real human
beings I actually did a whole other
video that went into this secret agenda
by the filmmakers that you should
definitely go check out still like Rey
this movie can't help but remind us of
the past
notice how Ray's spots Luke's x-wing
submerged in the water in a way that's a
nod to the Empire Strikes Back when Luke
tried to use the force to dredge his
x-wing out of the swamp water fact that
he just lets it sit sunken down there
tells us a lot about Luke's state of
mind he has no intention of leaving this
island or using the force to give him
the opportunity to do so also notice how
that fighter is missing the
panel from its wing if you look closely
at Luke's home you'll notice that he's
using that panel as a makeshift door so
rather than using this x-wing as a means
for escape he's using it to further
entrenched himself in this place
personally I really love the pores in
this movie unlike the Ewoks which a lot
of people are comparing them to the
parks are really just here for a pure
physical comedy and they never really
try to save the day it's actually super
funny when they die like for example I
think we all really wanted that one Korg
to ignite the lightsaber and the other
one was peering into the emitter oh
we're so close by the way these porks
were inspired by real-life puffins that
inhabit the island of skellig michael
where they shot all this stuff so they
weren't just random cash grabs by Disney
they were creatures inspired by
real-life nature that became cash crabs
like this thing inside Luke's home are a
few interesting Easter eggs first
there's this hanging necklace containing
a red crystal corn individual dictionary
that's a Jedi Crusader pendant a kind of
trophy that contains a Sith lightsaber
crystal unlike the blue and green Kyber
crystals that jedi use synth use red
synthetic ones
some believe that red crystal in there
might have been from the lightsaber of
Luke's father Darth Vader but the
description of Jedi Crusader could also
be a reference to a different sit from
the expanded the universe Darth Revan
who also began as a Jedi Knight who led
a group called the Jedi Crusaders
there's also this compass and that
should be familiar to those of you who
played Star Wars Battlefront 2 in the
game Luke actually finds this compass is
what leads him to this island on Asha -
when Xu Baca Kicks down the door I like
how Hamill momentarily softens his
character his voice reverting back to
his younger self from the original
trilogy it's almost like he dee ages 30
years whenever he's around r2 or Yoda
really anyone from the og like Carrie
Fisher Hamill does a remarkable job
handling that balance of how we remember
the character with the more hardened
soul that they would have aged into
moving on to the throne room of Supreme
Leader Snoke on board the supremacy
clearly it's meant to evoke the throne
room of Emperor Palpatine
being flanked by these red Praetorian
guards definitely recalls Palpatine's
red royal guard but these guys are way
more deadly than we ever got to see the
imperial guard speak as we see later
their true melee fighters with a variety
of different weapons and Snoke is
definitely more extravagant in a lot of
ways he prefers bright red curtains and
golden robes a choice that Andy Serkis
who voiced invoke at the character
Burgos based on hugh hefner
unfortunately we don't learn a lot about
Snoke this movie all those theories that
it could be Darth Plagueis the wise
Sidious his old master not quite
he's Jar Jar Alisa all we really know
about snoke's past is that he hails from
the Unknown Regions from mysterious
corner of the galaxy that it's gone up
in the EU novels the book aftermath
empires end includes a passage about
Palpatine sensing a presence in the
Unknown Regions which many believe could
have been Snoke waiting to take over in
his absence but if you look closely at
Snoke we do get some possible clues
about his origin he wears a ring on his
finger in the center is a black stone
that's obsidian which is the same rock
and the volcanic caverns beneath Darth
Vader's castle on Mustafar so it's
possible that snoke's origin could be
connected to the ancient Sith Cave that
Vader supposedly built his temple on
that ring is also engraved with images
of these four figures now these are the
four stages of dort see ancient
philosophers who date way back to the
early republic their names are Cicero's
FEI yan john and grete and these four
were more popular among the syph than
the jedi because they favored thought of
morality
encouraging exploration of the darkside
we've actually seen these four figures
before as statues and Palpatine's office
in Revenge of the Sith
so another theory is that Snoke is one
of these ancient sages perhaps Bharata
himself he was one who pushed the
darkside exploration the most it's kind
of like this Allah's are slither into
the group oh that was the voice of
millions of voices of nerds crying out
and tear at their computers in this
scene I like our Snoke begins by telling
kylo you wonder why I keep a rabid
current such a place of power because
weakness properly manipulated can be a
sharp tool he's referring to the
manipulating of Huck's in this moment
but by the end of the scene it's clear
he's also referring to the manipulation
of kylos weakness he mocks his
apprentices emulation of Vader calling
him a child and a mask when that mask
gets removed he may have noticed how the
scar on kylos face has changed position
from where it was at the end of the
force awakens then it went across the
bridge of his nose now it goes down the
one side of his face which makes him
look a lot like his grandfather did in
Revenge of the Sith I also love how John
Williams includes an echo of the
Imperial March when Vader gets mentioned
here but when kylo smashes his Vader
inspired helmet
Williams's kylo Ren music theme take
/ with the Imperial March never to be
heard again this is an example of how
kylo is letting go of his past releasing
himself from the impersonation that made
him a bit of a hat back on hunch - Luke
says Marais do you think I'm gonna walk
out with a laser sword and face down the
whole first order and that's interesting
for a couple reasons one Luke does
exactly that at the end of the movie
well the sort of a force projection of
and does that but also Luke says laser
sword not lightsaber this is actually a
throwback to George Lucas's original
drafts and story treatments for the Star
Wars script which used the noticeably
less elegant term of laser sword instead
of the more civilised lightsaber as Ray
follows Luke as he hikes around the
island we get more looks at aceh twos
interesting ammolite first you can see
the tale of a large sea creature
slipping beneath the waves behind Rey
but we also meet my favorite of these
creatures the palace sirens the
flippered marine animals that Luke
gathers yummy yummy green milk from and
yes this is green milk not to be
confused with the blue milk that Luke
drank on Tatooine that was a bantha milk
by the way that also showed up in rogue
one now these things are called Bala
sirens as a reference to Greek mythology
the sirens were creatures who lured in
sailors with an enchanting song that
would cause the ships to wrecked on the
rocks of the shore and yet how could you
not be lured in by these sexy ass chill
milk walruses mm-hmm moving on to Ray's
discovery of the ancient Jedi Temple
notice how it's housed in a hollowed-out
trunk of an ancient tree now in the past
I speculated that there could be a
connection with the force trees from the
legends stories shattered Empire but
actually this tree is called an Nettie
tree and the wood does have a spiritual
significance and wrote one the character
cheered in ways staff was made out of
you Nettie wood inside Luke repeatedly
asked sir a one of those 1000 questions
that was referenced before who are you
eventually Rey responds that she's from
nowhere which interestingly sets up the
underwhelming reveal of her parentage
later on as kylo helps her admit Rey is
truly a nobody from nowhere something
this movie teases in its first act right
here these books that Luke talks about
contain this symbol now this is a sigil
of the Jedi Order it takes the shape of
a lightsaber or laser sword flanked by
two wings later this would inspire the
same shape of the rebellion
which shows up again in this film's
closing frames now here ray references
The Awakening she experienced in the
force awakens and Luke responds by
saying you need a teacher now that's a
callback to kylos line in the force
awakens teacher and this sets up Luke
and kylo as competing influences on
Ray's future as a Jedi trainee now it's
here where Luke bums out Rey by stating
time and Mark Hamill said that he
initially wasn't a fan of Rian Johnson's
cynical take on the character of Luke
telling him I'd pretty much
fundamentally disagree with every choice
you've made but he said after getting
that off his chest he decided to do his
best to realize that vision oh Mark
Hamill does your good nature know any
limit what a great guy back on the rad
is Leia slapped Poe for disobeying her
order earlier on which Oscar Isaacs said
they did 27 takes up he ended up being
like 27 takes of Kari just leaning in
and every time she'd hit like a
different spot in my face Leia tells Poe
there are things he cannot solve by
jumping in an x-wing and blowing
something up I need you to learn that
this is another example of this thematic
separation from the past two films it's
the last Jedi's way of explaining how
Poe jump into next wing to blow up
Starkiller base as well as Luke jumping
in an x-wing to blow up the Death Star
in the first movie is kind of an overly
simple solution that doesn't apply to
all situations sometimes a Messier more
patient strategy is the wisest course I
go deeper into that lesson in my other
analysis so go check that out we get a
quick cameo from Admiral Ackbar here who
orders just sound the alarm
there's also a quick cameo from actress
Michaela Cole from Black Mirror as a
resistance communications officer who
says they found this as kylo leads the
assault on the resistance fleet you may
have noticed him doing a barrel roll
similar to his grandfather's move in
Revenge of the Sith and actually earlier
in Phantom Menace then we get this
fascinating moment of hesitation from
kylo that we saw in the trailer when he
has his mother Leia in his sights but he
decides not to fire now why does kylo
hold back here well on that thought I
have a pretty mind-blowing theory on
that that I will blow your mind with
later but and one of Rian Johnson's many
twists in this movie the bridge gets
destroyed anyway with kylos other TIE
fighters taking it out okay let's talk
about this insane scene with Leia
first off the composition of these shots
it's just gorgeous it's like a painting
something intended to look surreal and I
think that's my design Leia's embrace of
her force abilities here is kind of a
poetic ballet similar to Ray's surreal
encounter with the forest and the force
awakens this imagery actually connects
in an interesting way to an anecdote
Carrie Fisher brought up in her
one-woman show wishful drinking she
recalled how George Lucas told her she
couldn't wear a bra under her Leia
costume because in his words the
weightlessness of space causes your body
to expand and the underwear would
strangle you and Carrie Fisher jokes no
matter how I go I want it reported that
I drowned in moonlights strangled by my
own bra I don't know if it's intentional
but I think it's interesting how for the
briefest of moments we see Carrie Fisher
drowned in moonlight no word about any
strangling underground but the real
question is how is Leia able to do this
and return the Jedi she only began to
even learn of her connection of the
force which seems to have only
manifested so far in the form of
feelings and like minor clairvoyance but
according to this film's visual
dictionary Leia did begin training as a
Jedi after the events of Return of the
Jedi which might explain how she's able
to create this pocket of pressurized air
around herself and glide back into the
Rattus you look closely you can see some
layers of frost that form around her
skin those could be forming a sort of
bubble seal that allows her to survive
for at least a brief moment now some of
you suggested that Leia isn't moving
herself here but she's moving this [ __ ]
closer to her and that clay if that was
the case who wouldn't need to move all
the other pieces of debris that moved
behind her - and yeah that would take an
even more tremendous force than just
moving herself but one detail I loved
here is notice how when Leia looks back
in the wreckage of the bridge her body
passes through the hologram and the
supremecy severing it it's a really cool
visual foreshadowing for hold those kind
of cosmic strike later on
back atcha - Luke Reed boards the
Millennium Falcon and he retrieves these
golden dice now for those who don't
remember these were barely visible in
the first Star Wars Hayne at the top of
the frame in a falcon cockpit though
they didn't show up in the sequels
according to Pablo Hidalgo head of the
Lucasfilm story group it's rumored that
Han used these dice to win the
Millennium Falcon from Lando Calrissian
in a game Karelian spiked whether or not
that's true we do know that Han just
keeps them as a good luck charm
Luke uses them in this movie is a token
of Hans memory and of course we get
another sweep throw back to the original
film when r2 plays the old Leia
transmission back on the raddest we meet
Laura Dern's character vice admiral
emmalin old Oh
novel Leia Prince of Alderaan explains
how Leia and amylin were friends as
young women serving in the Imperial
Senate all those purple hair isn't just
a random detail here it's actually a
reflection of her rebellious nature as a
girl she started dying at a young age
because she wanted to go against the
grain of reference and notice that she
wears these two bracelets they're
designed with constellations that are
visible from her homeworld also from a
young age Aldo has been obsessed with
astronomy which actually serves her well
in this movie if she navigates the
Raddatz to an undisclosed rebel base now
as she addresses the troops we see
what's left of the resistance fighters
and started to tell where but somewhere
among these fighters either in this
scene her and others are more cameos by
director Edgar Wright and his brother
Oscar actors Navin Chowdhry and knowest
again who has actually appeared in all
of Bryan Johnston's films also make
cameos among the resistance across this
movie and there's definitely a shot of
our old pal nyan know who piloted the
Falcon with Lando and returned the Jedi
he also made appearance in the force
awakens
next up Finn runs into Rose Tico when he
tries to escape Rosa's uniform has the
Orbis letters GLD standing from brown
logistics division meanwhile you may
have noticed Finn's jacket is stitched
up you got that jacket from Poe in the
force awakens and later kylo Ren's
lightsaber burned a huge gash into it
the visual dictionary confirms that Finn
did this dish in himself I just like
that we get to see more of thins
scoundrel behavior in this movie with
him trying to [ __ ] rose by
heroically telling her may the force be
with you use these same exact bravado
that he tried to use on Rey and the
force awakens and after a fun cameo by
Maz Kanata
let's jump ahead to the first of Rayyan
kylos force base times the lighting
pulls off some interesting tricks to
connect these two notice now each has a
similar tiny beam of light on their
faces I mean I just like how this kind
of reflects the perception of Snoke as
he's peeking into each of their minds
outside we meet the caretakers of Aceh -
these are a race called the Lynnae now
all of these caretakers are females but
there are male the name
called the visitors who only there's a
part of the year for reading up on the
islands peak notice this pool of water
covering a mosaic pattern this image is
called the Prime Jetta it shows a
kneeling figure divided into light and
dark now someone suggested that this
image looks kind of like Snoke by the
way but I don't think that's the case
because snow doesn't really show any of
the light this figure seems to represent
but the figure is a reflection of the
first lesson that Luke explains to Rey
which honestly might be the best visual
explanation we've ever gotten to the
force in any Star Wars movie the editing
intercuts visual examples of all the
dualities that raise senses around the
island life and death warm and cold
peace and violence and the force as the
energy that connects all of these
polarities like that image of the Prime
Jedi this sequence provides such a
strong depiction of how the force is
actually something that requires both
good and evil elements rather than
something that we previously understood
really belong to the peaceful Jedi
we also see how this sense of balance
applies to the geology of the island
itself the surface is basked in sunlight
with no Teresa fried shady then but it
sits atop a very dark SIF cave which ray
will explore later on I also like how
Luke begins this lesson by teasing and
swatting a train which is actually how
we go to begin teaching him an empire
after this lesson Rey again force times
with kylo and I love the digital
parallelism once again this time between
the falling rain where ray is
and the raining sparks behind kylo on
the supremacy so yet another example of
those dualities of the different sides
of the force represents water and fire
okay moving on to Finn and roses search
for the master code breaker on canto
pipes the casino resorts for the wealthy
war profiteers of galaxies and you might
have noticed these trees that line the
city's streets according the visual
dictionary those trees are a species
native to Alderaan Leia's homeworld that
got destroyed can't abide kept them in
these seed banks of course Alderaan's
destruction made them a super rare
luxury and another example of how this
morally bankrupt society profits from
the pain and suffering of the rest of
the galaxy we also meet this one alien
dude complaining to the police that finn
and bros parked on his beat this guy is
named slowin low he apparently made a
fortune selling driftwood sculptures
which sound like a play
career that I definitely want slow in
low is a member of the added NATO race
kind of like the resistance fighter ello
Asty from the force awakens as an inside
joke the designers name all these other
NATO characters after songs by the
Beastie Boys which is a favorite of JJ
Abrams hello Asti was named after hello
nasty there were others named ilk Oh Moo
Nico for ill communication rude down for
root down and grass monkey or
intergalactic no brass monkey now slow
and low is named after slow and low and
he's voiced by Joseph gordon-levitt
longtime collaborator Brian Johnson now
inside the casinos are even more cameos
you can briefly see this flat nose
laughing an alien this guy's name is
wada Ben and he's played by Warwick
Davis keeping up with his tradition of
playing W named characters in Star Wars
movies he started as a kid playing
wicket the Ewok in return the Jedi he
played walled and weasel and Phantom
Menace Walla van and maz kanata's bar in
the force awakens and we teeth Q being
partisan fighter on Jenna in rogue one
there's also a cameo by Gary Fisher
Carrie Fisher's dog who plays space Gary
Fisher made up as an alien pup Mark
Hamill actually voices an additional
character for this scene da Bousquet the
Leprechaun looking dude who thinks bb-8
is a slot machine leader you can
actually hear Dobby laughing with his
cackle sounding very similar to Hamels
laugh as the Joker in Batman the
Animated Series the original master
codebreaker thereafter with the red
flower on his lapel is played by actor
justin theroux from the leftovers and
the woman accompanying him is named
lovely she's played by model actress
Lily Cole outside finding rose spots
some abused kids who work on the father
stables the main one who shows up in the
final scene of the film is played by a
cat named Pierce Gagnon Rian Johnson
previously worked with Kidd in the film
looper he plays a kid with some
terrifying telekinetic powers but makes
it interesting how he later proves to be
force sensitive in this movie - now not
everyone was crazy about this D story on
can't - bite largely because it feels
this a little out of place in the story
and I don't think it makes it bad
there's still an important reason this
is part of the last Jedi but that is
another thing that I go into in that
other video that you should definitely
watch but let's wrap up this canto bite
storyline and the jail cell Finn and
Rose run to Benicio del Toro's character
known only as DJ now his name and origin
aren't revealed explicitly in the move
but he has a cap that contains a tin
plate with Orbis letters reading don't
join that reflects DJ's neutral
worldview playing all sides to advance
his own interest as much as possible
when they break out of the cell notice
the helmets of the guards those letters
are our best for CB PD or can't abide
Police Department apparently the police
of this planet are completely controlled
by the wealthy elite like a private
security force now in order to escape
ROS gives the stableboy or resistance
ring according to the visual dictionary
that ring has been passed down over the
decades previously worn in the halls of
the Imperial Senate during the Galactic
Civil War with this secret entering
gradient to show proof of rebel loyalty
and right before they escape we get a
fun call back to the force awakens with
Finn's ship exploding right before they
get to it just like the one he and Ray
almost took in the Jack whose scrapyard
before choosing the Falcon instead ok
back to the Rays storyline when raid
trains with the bo staff and lightsaber
on the cliff John Williams scores her
with the Ray theme from The Force
awakens remember in that movie a play
while showing ray and her natural
element going through her daily routine
so bringing it back here suggests that
Luke sees ray with a lightsaber in hand
as someone in her natural element this
is the life she's destined to lead and
when that slab of Boulder crushes the
caretakers wheelbarrow for a second you
can make out but that wheelbarrow was
made out of bones a rib cage of some
large creature it might be the same
species that we saw briefly earlier when
ray described death in her forced vision
montage later when Luke lectures ray on
the failures of the Jedi philosophy he
mentioned that at the height of their
power they allowed for Darth Sidious to
take over it's interesting that Luke
says Darth Sidious and not Emperor
Palpatine the character was only ever
referred to as the Emperor or Palpatine
in the original movies his sif identity
wasn't really known in fact we didn't
really know him as Darth Sidious until
the prequels so Luke using this name
suggests that his ongoing study of the
force and perhaps communing with the
force ghosts of his father Yoda obi-wan
have recontextualized this political
tyrant as the city truly was moving on
to the reveal of why kylo Ren turned on
Luke Luke perceived snoke's influence in
kylos mind became fearful and drew his
lightsaber on him to kill the boy in his
sleep housing kylo to react defensively
now for a lot of fans
turn was a little hard to swallow I
guess this is a little dark for Lou but
when you've rewatched the original
trilogy this temptation by the dark side
definitely has precedent remember Luke
tapped into the dark side when he fought
Vader and returned the Jedi leni in his
anger flow through him was how he was
able to defeat his father Luke also
explains that this was a fleeting gut
reaction to his fear and that he
immediately regretted even considering
it I should also point out that this
concept of a man having to decide
whether to kill a boy whom he knows will
grow up to be evil and crazy powerful
basically the kill the Hitler baby
debates of time-travel is what me / Ryan
Johnson's previous film is all about
without spoiling anything from looper
the solution involves trying to change
the heart of the future villain by
correcting the mistakes you made to make
them that way
which is exactly what Luke tries to do
in this movie in another parallel to
Luke in the past film Rey furthers our
training by descending into a cave where
she experiences some trippy visions no
nothing like Luke's own face and the
Darth Vader helmet like an infant so
what exactly is going on in this mirror
seen it's pretty impressionistic but my
best explanation of what we're seeing is
an infinite number of rays reflecting
back to her kind of like when you stand
between two mirrors and you see an
endless mirror tunnel I think these are
all slightly different versions of Rey
along a spectrum between the light and
the dark side Rey began to sequence
facing one way but then she turns to the
darkest side representing her turn to
the dark side for answers about her
parents but then her perspective shifts
so that she's now at the end of that
dark side asking the reflective surface
to answer her core question who are her
parents and like the dark side always
does after it lures you in it doesn't
give you the answers it promised to
deliver it just leaves you with more
questions though this mirror only shows
Rey's reflection meaning her own selfish
interests should be her focus according
to this mirror at least this is how I
read it paint in Brian John says head
yet inevitably Rey turns on Luke
becoming what he feared the same way
kylo did this is the classic Jedi folly
by withholding certain truths from their
students to protect them they turn the
students away and force them to seek
those answers from bad influences you
know it's kind of like parents who are
afraid to teach their kids about sex so
those kids end up learning it from
older bad kids on the playground or you
know gross jokes by youtubers needs
moving on to Luke's attempt to burn the
Nettie tree and the return of Yoda now I
gotta say I love the decision to depict
Yoda in its classic Frank Oz voice
puppet form from Empire and Return of
the Jedi as opposed to this CGI version
that we saw in the prequels rather than
that super serious version Yoda was back
to his old self here cracking jokes
giggling bopping Luke on the head with
his cane and then blowing our minds is
some truly profound wisdom in a way that
wisdom kind of sets us at ease to the
graters teacher failures yes we don't
need to see the characters score a to
easy victory in this movie despite how
crowd-pleasing it could be a messy
failure will show us way more of these
characters true colors and we are what
they grow beyond that is a burden of all
masters inevitably the older generation
must be surpassed by the younger
generation and that's okay that's how we
move forward as a society may be Yoda
suggesting that it's not so crazy to say
these new Star Wars movies can be better
than the original ones I mean guys are
essentially the same stories but with
better action better jokes better
characters better effects oh god I can
hear those million voices again I'm
sorry I'm sorry I also like how Luke
Meyer ELLs that past moment with kylo
both tortured souls came close to
destroying a piece of their pasts Luke
the Jedi Temple and kylo his mother Leia
and then decide not to with their
weakness overtaking them but then nature
takes its course and they lose what they
loved anyway other Thai fighters took
out Leia and Yoda Simon freaking
lightning to ignite the trees also
notice that Yoda shrugs off the ancient
Jedi texts as they burn inside the tree
saying page-turners they were not and
that they contain nothing the girl
doesn't already possess now hold onto
slime because it comes back later
meanwhile when Ben Rosa DJ hacked
through the Supremacy shields DJ uses
the term slice now this is a reference
to the EU books where slicer is a word
for a hacker this is the first time
slicing has come up and been described
this way in a Star Wars film and
speaking of nerdy references we get this
goofy misdirect when what looks like a
shuttle releasing thrusters making a
landing oh but no it's just a droid
ironing some
uniforms this is a deep cut by ryan
johnson to hardware wars a short film
released in 1978 that recreated Star
Wars using household appliances the
ships including an iron it was a big
deal in the 70s and 80s when it was
harder for fanboys to get their hands on
any Star Wars content between the movies
ah to be alive in 2017 when half our
breakdowns of Star Wars movies come out
on YouTube within a week later on the
supremacy there's this other spherical
droid that spots bb-8 under the bin kind
of like an evil bb-8 now his name is
officially be t9e but the crew of the
last Jedi nicknamed him be bh8 bb-8 yeah
I explained the joke don't be be a hater
shortly after this they get caught and
DJ reveals he betrayed them basically I
guess DJ is kind of the last Jedi
equivalent of Lando Calrissian somewhat
eccentric cool dude whom the hero is
fine on a luxurious neutral ground boos
neutrality leads him to turn over the
heroes to the enemy I'm not saying DJ is
nearly as cool as Lando or nearly as
well-developed a character but he plays
a parallel function apply we also see
the return of Captain phasma Gwendolyn
Christie's character from the force
awakens
aka chrome dome as Finn later calls her
you may be wondering how phasma escaped
considering Finn and Han just kind of
left her in a trash compactor on
Starkiller base shortly before it blew
up Marvel Comics actually published a
five-issue miniseries about phasma that
explained what happened in the trash
compactor she apparently ran into a
trash monster similar to the DIA Noga
from the Death Star trash compactor but
she lucked out when a resistance bomb
opened a hole in the chamber she escaped
ran through a snowy forest where she saw
ray and kylo fighting and she escaped in
a TIE fighter before the planet exploded
she also covered her tracks from when
she lowered those shield slamming it on
another officer Sol Rivas and killing
him yeah not the best person later many
of those stormtroopers that we saw in
the background lining up around Finn
Rosen phasma may contain a number of
cameos now it's rumored that the British
Princes William and Harry plays
stormtroopers along with Tom Hardy and
British actor Gary Barlow now all these
guys definitely shot scenes in
stormtrooper armor but some of them may
have been part of scenes that got cut
then after a posed mutiny attempt on the
raddest Leia explains to him hold those
true plan to gradually get the
resistance to the abandoned secret rebel
base on crate that Lana
I mentioned earlier revealed that crate
was actually Leia's first introduction
into the rebellion as a young woman she
learned that her foster father Bail
Organa was secretly sending supplies to
crate and upon investigation discovered
the whole rebel base there and that bill
was part of the rebellion if she decided
to join as well so the planet crate
really goes back a long way for Leia and
for holed up in this goodbye scene
between Leia and hole though the
dialogue was largely written by Carrie
Fisher and laura dern including them
saying may the force be with you at the
same time Carrie Fisher was a well known
script doctor and actually contributed a
lot of lines to the script okay let's
move on to race surrendering herself to
kylo and snow gone the supremacy and he
probably knows the parallels between
this scene and Return of the Jedi when
Luke surrenders himself to Vader in the
emperor hoping to turn his father to
light ray is even framed the same way
Luke was during his surrender cuffed and
off to the left of kylo all the beats of
the scene Snoke torturing Rey showing
her how her friends outside are dying
kylo turning on his master they're all
parallel to Return of the Jedi and if
you listen closely the music here is
John Williams Emperor's theme from that
scene and this almost feels like that
kind of team-up victory that Luke and
Vader experience we get this amazingly
choreographed lightsaber melee with Rey
and kylo teaming up and in the final
move rage shouts bend as she assists
with the lightsaber and he takes out the
guard over the shoulder it just feels
like these two are gonna be together
forever but Brian Johnson only does this
to once again subvert our expectations
rather than killing Snoke for redemptive
reasons like Vader did with Palpatine
and joining Rey in the light
kylo reveals that he only did this with
much darker intentions actually made a
whole other video explaining Kyla's
decision and how it's connected to his
decision to kill his father in a force
awakens and where the movie killed off
snowcat all go check it out another
detail I liked here Snoke getting
severed at his midsection including his
hand getting severed at the wrist this
keeps the last Jedi in the Star Wars
tradition of character is getting
freakishly amputated in every movie even
a deleted scene from The Force awakens
featured unkar plutt getting his arm
ripped off by Chewie another moment of
subverted expectations Kiley reveals to
Rey her parentage and again Johnson
builds up this reveal by echoing a past
Star Wars moment kylo tells her you know
the truth which totally echoes Vader
telling Liu
you know this is it they're related
something huge
they were nobody ray says and kylo
responds who were filthy junk traders
who sold you out for drinking wonder
daddy no papa
great one Jack desert by taking away the
preciousness of this reveal Johnson
forces us to focus on these two people
in the room right now and it leaves a
hole in Ray's heart that kylo is
dangerously close to filling and the
director keeps that idea of the hero
being tempted to join the dark side
while keeping alive that feeling a
possibility that heroes really can come
from anywhere which to be honest the
original trilogy kind of lost by making
Luke part of a famous bloodline hold oh
using the raddest final Lightspeed jump
to tear through the supremacy is one of
the coolest images a Star Wars scene has
ever given us so Wade Johnson cuts out
the audio and just allows a pure visual
element to speak for itself really makes
this moment pop the intercutting editing
also helps build up to this climax Rey
and kylo split Luke's lightsaber and
phasma orders execute as if all these
actions are part of one swift motion to
split and execute the first order
flagship and the fight that follows I
like the reveal that bb-8 was piloting
the eight CST which felt like a nod to
the reveal and Return of the Jedi that
Chewbacca was piloting the walker moving
to this film's third act on crate the
world-building of this planet is
fantastic with these crystal fox
creatures they're called volp toises or
a singular bolt X which yeah sounds a
lot like the Pokemon Vulpix and that's
because they have a similar etymology
bulb is a Latin meaning Fox the red
mineral Laden soil covered with a white
salt layer creates such a vibrant
contrast the neutral white reflecting
the first order stormtroopers and the
crimson red reflecting the dying
resistance which is been hemorrhaging
fighters this entire film as their
rust-bucket speeders charged tore them
the stabilizing anchors make it look
like they're bleeding across the
landscape as if this charge is doomed
from the start
really the Battle of crate totally
echoes the Battle of Hoth in the best
ways mostly for the great visual of
these massive walkers looming across the
white tundra which by the way those are
called gorilla walkers which have these
heavily armored front legs and are much
larger than the older model Imperial 88
es you can actually see some of those
older models being used as Scouts in
this battle
and chewy and Ray are just so much fun
to watch in the Falcon seen it outrun
the TIE fighters and a narrow red
crystal cavern definitely echoes the
Falcons run through the second Death
Star and Return of the Jedi and Turing
all this we do get a little meta joke
that this isn't a total Hoth ripoff a
resistance fighter points out that the
surface is salt not ice actually that
fighter beside him is Gareth Edwards who
directed rogue one
he allowed Brian Johnson to make a cameo
in rogue one Johnson was a Death Star
operator on the catwalk that the focus
being fires out there's actually a more
important reason this scene wants us to
pause and look at the red footprints and
the salt that I'll get to in a bit Poe
ordering Finn to fall back shows an
important step for his characters growth
he's essentially passing on the wisdom
that Leia barked at him earlier and that
Yoda spoke to Luke failures sometimes is
an option and it's a valuable learning
tool sometimes things are more
complicated than jumping in a cockpit
and blowing things up what does it
matter if no one survives to fight
future battles Poe learning this lesson
definitely positions him to step up as a
leader of the resistance in episode 9
okay let's talk about this gut-wrenching
Luke and Leia reunion Brian Johnson said
that the set on this day the scene was
shot felt like a church the way everyone
became so quiet
reverent for the importance of this
moment and I think what I love most
about this is the scene serves as a kind
of secret funeral for Han Solo even
though he's never mentioned by name it
starts with Leia joking about her new
hair which is a line Carrie Fisher wrote
by the way but remember this braid is an
all Deranian mourning tradition
reminding us about Hans death and when
Luke begins to talk Leia just cuts him
off saying I know now it's a small
moment but first Star Wars fans I know
it's basically Leia code for I love you
again
echoing Han know and on top of all this
the music that plays here is John
Williams's theme for Leia in Han from
the original movies and if it still
wasn't clear Luke says no one's ever
really gone and gives Leia Hans lucky
dies from the Falcon Luke is essentially
saying that no one truly departs this
world so long as they live on in our
memories after the scene there's another
wink - Han Threepio begins to tell pode
the odds of their survival 15,000 for
228 to 1 and post snaps of them just
shut up this is a callback to Han stem
and a Threepio and Empire the
possibility of successfully navigating
an asteroid field
folks in the 3722 whatever tell me the
odds
another big twist comes at the end of
the epic battle between Luke and kylo
when Luke reveals that it's not actually
him there he's still back on aceh too
this is a force projection of himself
and if you were looking closely there
were a number of little clues that
indicated this first Luke's appearance
he looks younger with shorter hair this
was the age he looked when he fought
been in those flashback scenes implying
this is how he looked when Leia last saw
him
also he just kind of magically appears
inside the crepe face even though they
just established that there was no other
way in or out of the mine aside from
those tiny cracks in the boulders of the
volt assists lit through most obviously
he uses his old blue lightsaber which we
just saw ray and kylo split in half in
the supremacy also his lightsaber should
have been the green one he had at the
end of Return of the Jedi and those
flashbacks that's if he's still haven't
had it he probably chucked it in some
porkness but my favorite indicator are
those red footprints in the salt that I
mentioned earlier that one shot shows us
a close-up of kylos foot as it pivots in
the salt leaving a red mark shortly
after we see Luke's foot take a step but
the salt doesn't move it's almost like
his foot hovers over the salt and while
this all seems like another bonkers
extension of force abilities in this
movie there actually is precedents for
this in the expanded universe stories in
the dark empire series Luke projects
doubles of himself and in the dawn of
the Jedi comic series agents of the dark
side projects shadows and themselves
across long distances without leaving
their point of origin but of course Luke
lowering his saber and allowing kylo to
strike him is definitely a nod to Obi
Wan's move against his former apprentice
in the first film as he fades away he
taunts kylo see around kid this is
essentially Luke's version of if you
strike me down I shall become more
powerful than you can ever imagine and
this presents an interesting idea
Luke's saying this here and telling Leia
earlier no one's ever really gone
suggest that the ghosts of the people
Syd killed might continue to haunt them
after their deaths like perhaps in
addition to living on as a voice guiding
Luke obi-wan could have lived on in
Vader said to driving him crazy like you
better believe Luke's force ghost is
gonna mess of kylo every night hovering
over his bed with a green lightsaber
better lie on those sheets kylo but it's
also possible that the reason kylo held
back earlier
when he had his mother in his sights was
that another ghost was haunting him in
that moment his father hot on emotional
level maybe he just didn't want to
repeat of that pain that he felt for
murdering the last parent good name I
would love it if kylo sees a literal
ghost a Paris aboard floating around him
at all times
saying then if you fire on that bridge
both me and your mother are gonna be
following you around no you don't want
that we get two more callbacks to the
original trilogy Rey has to use her
force power to lift rocks to clear a
path for the resistance very similar to
how Luke has to lift boulders back on
Dagobah and of course Luke's final scene
takes him back home to Tatooine as he
watches a binary sunset feeling a sense
of peace and finding the purpose his
characters sought as a boy at the start
of his journey as a dozen or so
remaining resistance fighters escape on
the Falcon there's a quick shot of Finn
looking in a drawer if you look closely
you can see those books the ancient Jedi
texts Rey apparently took them from the
tree aa notch to before it burned down
that gives new meaning to Yoda's words
earlier that the library inside
contained nothing that the girl doesn't
already possess you know still not
totally clear what these books contain
maybe some textbook explanations of the
force maybe instructions on how to build
or repair lightsabers Leia's final line
of the film we have everything we need
at first seems a little unclear but it
makes more sense in the film's great
closing scene those kids from Kanto bite
reenact the events of the Battle of
crate with toy versions of Luke in the
first order walkers I just love how this
bookends the film which opened with a
storybook framing line of a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away
it closes with this framing seen that
recontextualizes the previous events
from the point of view of children
almost as if to say hey don't take this
too seriously these stories are meant to
be escapism from our dull lives and to
appeal to our inner childlike sense of
wonder and imagination also it paints
Luke with the legend status he initially
hated and it shows how that legend is
actually more impactful than any
on-the-ground victory or loss could have
been this story of the battle is being
used as propaganda to recruit a new
generation of resistance fighters
that is what Leia meant by having
everything they need they have an
inspiring story and most importantly
that story inspires someone who is
essentially a nobody a future Rey with
his own force of
he holds his broom handled like a
lightsaber and looks to the stars to
dream as one of those stars shoots
across the night sky as long as kids
like this exist in the universe there's
always hope and just to ruin this sweet
moment for you this same kid in the
movie looper did this yeah the first
order screwed here's a question for you
guys do you think vice-admiral whole
dough should have told Poe Dameron about
her plan do you think that would have
settled the difference between them or
would a Poe have reacted even more
obtusely to this strategy and another
question I'm curious to hear from you
guys about how does the last Jedi rank
for you compared to all the other Star
Wars movies now for me it goes the
original Star Wars then the last Jedi
then the Empire Strikes Back the force
awakens Revenge of the Sith Return of
the Jedi
rogue one Phantom Menace then attacking
clones that's right Revenge of the Sith
is a lot better than you remember go
re-watch it but I want to know your
thoughts comment down below or tweet me
directly at EI vas and follow new rock
stars on Twitter at new rock starts or
updates under videos like and share this
video and subscribe to new rockstars and
be sure to check out all the other last
Jedi videos we've been doing a review we
did as a panel my explanation of kylos
decision to kill Snoke and my deeper
analysis of why I think a lesser die is
so polarizing among fans and why I think
it deserves another rewatch if you
really like this channel you can
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our donors especially Kenny
Smith guys thanks for watching bye